Hampton Maryland a proud Community
located just outside of Baltimore and
home to Cafe hunt a restaurant whose
name is special meaning to the local
population and what's your name Han Khan
has a term of endearment when you're
being friendly that's what you say
seihan bomber people love the word han
it's their word you know yeah open by
entrepreneur Denise Whiting in 1992 Cafe
hun quickly became a local Landmark Cafe
hun
hugs you
when you get here it's just food family
and fun with her business doing well
Denise decided to capitalize on
Baltimore's love affair with the word
hun she not only trademarked Cafe high
but the word hun as well Denise wanted
to make money she wanted to sell her
mugs her t-shirts her little knick-knack
things
and a backfire Denise Whiting the owner
of Cafe hun and she said she would go
after anyone that uses the word han
Denise had Baltimore behind her and then
she announced that she trade Marcon and
that ticked off a big portion of
Baltimore
this thing gets spun in this crazy way
they Lodge a boycott on the restaurant I
mean now I'm the villain
I'm the bad person
since the whole hun controversy there
has been a decline in business but it's
you know dropped dramatically since all
this has started did you
need oh come on really what is this
supposed to be she can be very harsh I'm
surprised that I have anyone left in the
kitchen to be honest with you I want you
to go downstairs and I want you to give
me a roll of paper towels
that are perforated there's one way to
do it here my way what's this Johnny why
is it sitting there is this for
something
when we have somebody that's not able to
lead us we're serving terrible food and
it sucks
do you want any of my bristles no it's
pretty much been Hell she's not helping
in the kitchen she doesn't know what
she's doing she's going to run us down
to the ground and if Chef Ramsay doesn't
come in we're screwed we really are I'm
done I'm gonna go broke at this rain
it's not fair and it's not right that
these Anonymous people that are out
there trashing your business and people
are listening
is this what I'm supposed to keep doing
am I supposed to keep fighting for what
I believe in for what I've spent 20
years of my life just building
[Music]
after learning of the funds Scandal Chef
Ramsay stops by a local radio station
hoping to get a better understanding as
to why the community has turned its back
on this restaurant today's best Music
Mix 106.5 have the best day ever we'll
see you tomorrow morning it's JoJo
Reagan all right that's a wrap
likewise
um thanks for giving a couple of minutes
your valuable time
um I'm dying to find out in terms of a
reputation Cafe home how is the food
Reagan oh I I've only eaten there two or
three times but the food is is on the
back burner why when you talk about Cafe
hun talk about Denise Whiting she
trademarked the term hun which is a
cultural icon in Baltimore I mean it's
it's a term of endearment locally
locally it's huge in this community I
mean it just represents friendliness
this welcoming pun is a word that was in
our vocabulary in Baltimore long before
it was part of a restaurant name she
went to a newspaper and said I own it I
own the word locally everyone's happy
with the name of the Russian but they
just weren't happy with her trying to
own something that belonged to the town
as opposed to her sure she was
threatening businesses with losses the
lawsuits I mean it went that far she had
had apparently you know thrown out some
cease and desist letters to people who
were using it she demanded legal fees
from somebody that was making tourist
stuff with just the word hun on it that
didn't say Cafe high oh dear what's the
feeling now has the business suffered on
the back of that the people who were
most offended were the people in that
immediate neighborhood yeah I mean she's
almost become the anti-hunt yes wow
well thank you for the Insight yeah I'm
here to help turn that place around
let's turn it around yeah but let me say
we've got our work cut out already I
haven't even been to the restaurant yet
I haven't tasted the food yet yes
thank you good to see you thank you
likewise do you know how to find the
restaurant Big Pink Flamingo you can't
miss it so they get what like it's a big
pink flamingo on the outside like a
full-size Flamingo
60 feet or so
come on no seriously yes I look for a
pink flamingo yeah thank you take care
[Music]
Russia with the flamingo
holy mackerel look at the size of that
thing
wow these are you serious look at that
wow wow wow wow
hey how are you hello hello Chef Ramsey
Harris manager Deborah nice to see you
what was that creasing I just made a
dessert whipped cream whipped cream
thank you for that I'm sorry I was just
so excited to see him I didn't even
think about washing that whipped cream
off
okay
Denise is going to not she's not going
to be herself I believe she's going to
pretend to be that perfect little
darling and I hope that Gordon Ramsay
really can see through
any facade she will put up you look
unhappy
come on I know why why are you upset
I mean business pretty much was half of
what it was last year I've taken
everything I had and put it in here I
mean I completely evaporated my
small Ira that I had I sold a house
everything's gone into here my last
ten thousand went in two weeks ago oh my
God I just didn't know what to do
anymore so what happened how did it
start going badly the problem is I
federally registered the Han as a as a
trademark right uh years ago somebody
picks up that I federally registered hun
and starts saying that I have stolen
something from the city of Baltimore
the newspapers radio television they
belittle demeaned I have people scream
at me from across the street just
horrible things oh yeah I mean I was
afraid for my life you felt that
threatened yeah
for your life yeah what Death Race well
people wishing me dead why would they
want to be so vicious to you if they
don't know me
it's hard to believe that it's just
because you registered the word hun and
you've done nothing else nothing else
there's nothing else that managed to
piss off anybody else
I'm not aware of anything else I've done
did you not Sue anyone I never sued
anybody you didn't sue anybody no did
you threaten to sue anybody no
I've done my homework before I got here
I did I you know you're not being fair
now well I did a seasoned assist you did
I did enforce a legal letter threatening
to sue someone using that now you've
been very devious
um you know I'm trying to get to the
bottom of it but I'm not going to
extract blood out of the stone I want to
work with you but make it very different
for me when you don't tell me the truth
[Music]
after being disappointed by Denise's
cover-up of the pr problems at Cafe hun
time for lunch Gordon can now begin to
focus on the food
hello hello chef and this is hi I'm
Janet Janet nice to see you darling how
long have you been here how much 20
years 20 years wow and this is Lynn nice
to see you darling how long have you
been here eight years wow and this is
Amanda Amanda I love the hair beautiful
I do this myself in the bathroom wow wow
wow the key is hairspray hairspray
hairspray Hairspray
enjoy your lunch thank you very much
indeed
wow
[Music]
two seconds who is that on the front
cover there that's nice is that Denise
yes that's Denise looking wonderful
looking wonderful wonderful a wonderful
sorry wow
[Music]
Denise thinks that she's a rock star
and everything's just in your face
Denise
um right what would you recommend the
Big Bay Club it has our shrimp salad and
crab cake well let's start off with that
shall we yes okay and I'll go for the
much better the moms
as in better than mums at home then your
own mom yeah wow okay great what else I
gotta go for the Bulma fish and chips
it's bomber
Balinese
thank you
[Music]
sword for honey honey love it amazing
thank you Paul
[Music]
all right we can go on the Big Bay you
know I used to just say you know serve
good food and the people will come this
is what a show always tastes like
tastes perfect
we need you to serve good food but the
people don't come big bang is that my
big bag
are you taking that or you may take it
go ahead
Tower of seafood
Big Bear Club
what's in there this is a layer of
shrimp salad a layer of long crab cake
bacon and lettuce and tomato thank you
how the hell do you start eating
sandwich this way I mean honestly
squash noodle down
I surrender to break it down
deconstructed
[Music]
wow the crab delicious it's a very
pleasant surprise let me tell you
because it's nice layer of crab
and then these stone cold shrimp
underneath horrible Amanda of course
this but here I mean they taste like
they're a week old would you mind
got that ghastly
Taste of the fridge does have a weird
Africa it's horrible it almost tastes
like the tainted yeah that's a mess I'll
leave that one Daddy
they said the uh he said the shrimp
taste that they had like a weird
appetizer like almost tastes like really
the refrigerator doesn't matter he said
they taste like they're old
a lot of the main items are crap it's
Denise's recipes it's the way she wants
it done
I don't understand this is perfect
and he's never thinks she's wrong this
is perfect and that's her biggest
downfall
yeah crispy please
[Music]
pull dark nope
a little dark it's good enough are we
happy with us I'm taking us Denise just
take it Denise does what Denise wants to
do and she won't listen to me she won't
listen to anyone else no I should have
gone out like that it's aggravating
English style fish and chips wow English
style holy mackerel house cut fries from
fresh potatoes and what kind of fish is
it uh cod fish cod fish wow
is it me is everything just greasy
no yeah
okay grace thank you thank you
fries
it doesn't even stick to the fish
yeah stressful I'm a shame Amanda it's
dry fish is dry well the whole batter
just sort of it's almost like peels away
from it
those fries or shame you don't like the
fries
soggy look at my fingers yeah we have
the chips and the tastiest thing on the
plate is the Tata sauce it's a big
disappointment I love fish and chips
wow
the cops are doing the best that they
can with the way they've been told to do
things so it's nice as far what's wrong
greasy fish fry the Batters just falling
off of it
said the fries they were mushing really
that's weird and they squeezed it in all
this like grease was all over his hand
french fries you know you get some
potatoes that are one way and sweet
potatoes are another way and having a
problem with the consistency of the
potatoes I mean it's just making me
crazy that's right
do you have the meatloaf coming off like
now
jeez
this one is and the meatloaf thank you
much better than mom's meatloaf that is
a very bold statement thank you
it's like a flamingo turd just landed on
my plate wow Rockies roll
it's Dreadful what a shame
damn that was disappointing that's the
actual flavor yeah and the uh Demi glass
is just so thick
sometimes it can be runny today it's
actually thick it's just mild everything
like a big thick varnish that just takes
nothing whose recipe is this
um I believe it's anesis better than
mum's memo thank God my mum's not
joining for lunch today thanks honey yes
sir wow and when you ask someone to
taste that broccoli the broccoli oh well
yes and the mush is cold yeah
okay he wants you to try the broccoli so
the broccoli is almost Raw
the match is cold and the demi glaze is
too thick and the meatloaf is Bland
okay every time he had a comment or a
criticism it's pretty ridiculous I've
been here for 20 years I hadn't done
something right maybe he's not the
answer are we done
go through the kitchen he's going to say
hello to meet everybody hi guys hello oh
hello uh this is right Greg I'm too sure
you work on the Donate fish yes do you
think she's gonna listen to anything he
says I hope so I don't think she will
she might snap freak out like the yeah
this is a
comfort food restaurant right yes and
when I think of comfort food I think of
meatloaf and excitement that's plan
and the Big Bay Seafood sandwich
crab delicious but underneath you've got
these stone cold shrimp it's horrible
aftertaste fish and chips the fish is
overcooked the batter is just falling
off it and you hand cut those fries yes
they cooked treadfully do you season
them and taste them before they go out
we do not season the fries you don't
season fries no we don't
this is you
yeah but you told them they can't season
a fry
fast food joints seasoned fries for
God's sake
does no one care
I mean there's not much to say you know
it's what we have it's the mini that we
have laid out and it's the recipe better
we can do you enjoy cooking this I don't
drink cooking Armenian food it's it's
dull I mean when we do try to change
things you know it's always oh I don't
like it like this you know we who
doesn't like it Bernice
so you're telling me you can do
best menu
I thought the problems were on the
outside you've got them on the inside
and the outside combine both and I'm
amazed you're still open I know that we
have a good product and I'm not gonna
let
anybody get in my way
including Chef Ramsay
covering that Denise's food might be as
bad as Cafe Hun's PR
IDE in Flamingo Chef Ramsay is anxious
to see how the kitchen handles a busy
dining room do this
how are you all tonight
spread that Chef Ramsay is in Baltimore
and the dining room was full for the
first time in a year you got fish and
chips working and the kitchen is now
dealing with a flood of orders got
asparagus for that and I can get it out
of your hand yeah
let's start falling to the table let's
get there
all right can you fix that asparagus so
it's all nice and neat you know I got
three steaks in here I really don't care
Greg
when Denise comes in and her Chef
clothes it's like having a hurricane in
there she just goes hectic and you know
you know I want this done now I went
down this way all right
guys all right I'm tired of seeing the
asparagus dumped in a bin all different
kinds of ways you know you start with
the small things we always get little
lessons from Denise and it's frustrating
because you just can't stop then
everything backs up and it's it's it
just causes a lot of problems you cut
off the ends and you blanch them you
hold those asparagus see where they
break at so you know where to come up
okay all right gray Cable ONE you're
waiting a long time I really really been
waiting a long time I don't have time to
stand around and watch her do this when
I have other you know jobs to do I feel
like I'm on the Titanic I need that
cracked up for 22. take us to 57.
despite the knees slowing down her
kitchen with an asparagus lesson all
right I'm taking
them take very hot and then your wings
will be right out some of the dishes
still manage to make their way out to
the diners there's a pool of Greece
Syria would be
this there's like a hair I can't believe
there's a hair because the turkey's just
like the crumbling apart
what's wrong with that overcooked and
they said they look like mushrooms what
is that turkey for stuffing they did not
like this I'm getting something oh my
God
all right this turkey we're not serving
it anymore 86 the turkey any turkey on
the board 86 the turkey
medium didn't they yes you did okay I'll
get it medium
table five wanted a medium steak what's
wrong it's a Well buy one in medium this
is well they're medium match
those sweets I don't want to use those
steaks give me give me a table 52. give
me all those steaks put them in there
wig alert all servers that we have no
steaks another orders I have no steak
are you serious yeah took the ones we
had throw them out all this you threw
them all out that's that's the whole
table your knees threw them out there's
nothing I can do table 52 Denise through
the mouth this is something that Denise
normally does 86ing things 86 biscuits
you guys they don't like it 86 the pot
pie 86 the catfish instead of fixing an
entree in the moment she pulls the
entire food item from service
okay
we don't have to redo everything oh my
gosh
I swear to girls you guys 86 the french
fries oh my god wow fish and chips we
have the chips we need to find out about
all the tables and have french fries on
their tickets that are not getting
french fries
we are at a price for the fish and chips
what would you like
86 the sweet fries 86 sweet fries we
have nothing to serve after 86 every
meal item
inside why are we ate six in this sweet
fries 86 sweet potato fries we got the
[__] cooking I don't get it I'm
just I'm in pain here okay
as my name here continues we're out of
15 prices
today's kept pulling stuff we now have
to walk to the table and tell him the
food's not there I can only apologize
for many times to somebody
I'm embarrassed by it you want a hug no
all right
as the menu items keep dwindling folks
we're out of pot pie I'll take it off
your check honey I apologize the diner's
patience is dwindling as well what about
these they left
they left
I've never seen you like this I've never
seen anything no so dysfunctional I've
never seen a kitchen work so backwards
you can't keep customers waiting an hour
for food and then 86s find out the total
amount that we can't thank you
oh Jesus
uh what the [__] was all that about
honestly yeah and is she always like
that yes how'd you concentrate like that
so you can't and you really can't I was
she 86 and everything how can I tell you
I've got 601 and boys and 150 almost in
discount so that's 750 total wow yeah I
mean that is ridiculous it is
thank you guys thanks Jeff crazy Gordon
Ramsay has got to get through her thick
skull if she doesn't take his advice
We're not gonna make it
I don't know I stop I mean I just yeah I
that was a disaster you know we can't
800 worth of food okay
team in the middle of sewers and show
them how to put asparagus on the plate
we're focusing in all the wrong areas
how can you let it go this far okay
somehow I got I got derailed if I can
simplify the menu down to something
that's really manageable and we just do
wonderfully simple delicious comfort
food
because I
you're confusing me before
you can talk about anything else you've
got to get the basics right you've got
to get the core the foundation because I
think you've lost the plot
I
you you need to sit down and have a
think
about what this expression hasn't got is
a clear Direction and restaurants run
from the top it starts from the top and
when the leader's gone the restroom's
gone
I don't know where to start
sorry
jeez
we'll get these mats out of here
[Music]
clearly Denise is in denial about how
she mismanages the restaurant take a
seat please so this morning Chef Ramsay
decides to pull together a staff meeting
before she arrives okay right that was a
tough one yesterday yes yes
and the only way we are ever going to
move forward is it we get out in the
open what's bothering you in the way
that Denise is running the restaurants
[Music]
basically when she's not here it runs
quite smooth but when she comes in pull
them around the restaurant just drops
she doesn't even have to say anything
but we know something's gonna happen
we're afraid of what she's gonna do it's
awful how she talks to the people she
goes up towards to the girls and tells
them they're stupid or she gets up to my
face tell her to fix our hair put a
flower in her hair that's why the
customers aren't coming in because you
want to flower in your hair she's
getting too carried away she focuses on
a lot of The Superficial things she
micromanages it's insane I mean really
insane last night she went 86 crazy
right yeah nearly a dozen items 86 the
fish and chips 86 the beef is this
normal yes she doesn't take
responsibility for anything so why are
we standing up to her we're all afraid
to tell her anything negative she'll
fire them she'll fire them boys she told
a couple of us if you say negative
things I don't need you with me
I appreciate your honesty however you
need to get that message across that
Denise gotta start standing up for
what's right I want you all to do that
right now oh my God you're probably
gonna get fired right now
this morning Chef Ramsay has heard an
array of grievances about Denise she's
getting too carried away we're all
afraid to tell her anything negative he
knows full well that for this restaurant
to move forward the staff needs to come
clean with their boss
[Music]
we're all gonna get fired right now
come over please
[Music]
uh right I saw a lot yesterday and I
wanted to catch up with the team and
some of the crap they've had to endure
and tolerate it's actually quite
horrific I'm amazed that they're still
here I'm now going to ask them to open
up and be honest with you
I didn't think we would have to tell her
to her face what we thought Debbie
please
Denise you um
your rude [__]
and I'm tired of it
I feel like I don't even know you
anymore you're just too mean with with
the employees you're talking to them
like [__] Denise you're the negative in
the restaurant
you make me feel like I'm not good
enough Denise I feel very unappreciated
I do anything you ask me and you come in
and scream at me what is going on do you
not trust me oh Janet I trust you how do
I know this unless you tell me
wow thank you
Greg please you're coming in you're
screaming you're a hundreds on the lawn
you're a hindrance you know and the crap
you're controlling everything and yet
you've got a brigade front and back of
house that are loyal and hardworking and
can get the job done Denise your ego is
huge and you think because you're Denise
Whiting you can do anything you have to
stop feeling sorry for yourself that
nobody likes you we've already
established that people don't like you
it is tough love
but
this is so important Debbie what's the
matter I'm just afraid about this place
going on out of business
after all I've put them through I'm just
so humbled and so grateful that they're
still with me
to lose this business
would be for me to Lose My Soul
and
[Music]
I appreciate
everything
that everybody does here I love each and
every one of you I've just been off
and I know that
I know I've come into the kitchen and
I've been difficult I'm sorry that I've
been
a bit overbearing I'm gonna step back
and let everybody do what they do so
well and
I can only say that
this is the beginning of a new day
she seems sincere now but I'm a little
doubtful about what
she's going to do as far as changing
very doubtful the way
sad to say thank you
[Music]
now that Denise has recognized the
morale problems of her restaurant hi
ladies Chef Ramsay knows that he needs
her to fully understand why the
community continues to be upset with her
I put together a select group of people
that I'd like you to hear from okay okay
please jump in the car that's a song
listen carefully
and I'll come back oh my God these
people they're gonna crucify me I'm
gonna be thrown to the wolves
I was like to take this moment
for you to help me to understand
why Cafe hun
and its owner Denise
have angered this community
who'd like to go first
what she really tried to do was
appropriate an identity it's like going
to Australia and trademarking mate
or y'all in the south
she's acting like a bully why is she a
bully anybody who would like to use the
word is at risk of receiving a cease and
desist order from her lawyers that says
change your name or else and I have a
website called Welcome to Baltimore hun
they see some desist letter that she
sent
wow I mean that's pretty severe
transcends the restaurant industry she
had gone to the Maryland Transit
Administration for their hun ad campaign
and forced them to give her creative
control basically the Maryland state
government has to go to Denise Whiting
for her approval
but that
but she's not in the right and that's
what people recognize yeah it's just
about money for her it's not about
Hampden it's not about anything it's
just money he pushes everyone around
she's focused on Denise whining and if
you don't like it you're going to be
sorry I have seen her
nasty she's made a mockery of who we are
and then tried to profit from it and I
think that's very egregious the damages
done all the citizens of Baltimore were
the ones that stopped going they are not
gonna go use that restaurant no way ever
what would it take
for this community to embrace Cafe hun
again she has to walk away from the
trademark she has to abandon it all
claim to it so it was a mistake she does
not own it it doesn't belong to anybody
right I'm very grateful for your Insight
thank you so much for coming I
appreciate it thank you
[Music]
yeah
I didn't get it before I was just so
angry at all the things that were
happening and didn't know how to handle
them and I was in denial I get it now
it's hard in there there's so much hate
what directed in in my direction there
was you did go off a few people you did
send letters where they were absolutely
freaking out to sort of stand up against
but when you threaten people or they
feel threatened they're gonna Revolt do
you realize you've made a mistake yes
you have to do something you have to
take responsibility and make a gesture
do you agree
[Music]
I absolutely agree you're not just
saying that because I'm here you know
yeah we've got a big issue here and and
and it's not me you have to convince
it's the city of Baltimore everything in
my life has been a disaster in the last
several months and I'm the only one that
can change that however I don't I don't
really know what I'll do
it appears as though Denise has seen the
error of her ways and so Chef Ramsay
decides to go ahead with the renovation
of Cafe hunt
morning ladies good morning nice to see
you today is the beginning of a new year
are you ready to see your new
restaurants yes welcome to New Cafe hun
jump in please oh my God that is so
gorgeous look at this Beauty
[Music]
look at this oh my gosh I always wanted
them all pink I always wanted boxes for
the teapots always always gorgeous
gone all those hideous colors
and assistance bright Vibrance in the
local restaurant let's look at the huge
stunning artwork that is a tribute to
hun glamorous gorgeous and something
that belongs to the restaurant let's get
that right I love it it's simple it's
elegant and it's clean everything just
kind of Blends together so perfectly I
really feel like we have a future in
Hamden can't help but love it welcome to
the flamingo room
oh this is so adorable is this a party
room or what look at the chandelier
what'd you think oh come on
we love it
I am so
happy it's like the sun came up over the
cafe hun on a gorgeous day it's gonna be
better it's going to be better than it
thank you with everyone clearly
Overjoyed about the physical changes to
the restaurant take a little lineup have
a look at this amazing food Chef Ramsay
is now ready to unveil the revamped menu
okay let's start off from the top shall
we that's chili beef tomatoes onions
Peppers Cheese service and Cornbread
traditional and classic puns hot crap
dip this one's done with Maryland crabs
gorgeous next to that you've got the
mini shrimp and crab rolls delicious the
entrees obviously the Maryland crab cake
this one's gonna fly out the door thank
you oh yes I love you for that next to
that Classic Fish and Chips crispy
delicious there is no soggy batter there
let me tell you absolutely beautiful
amazing next to that you've got a
delicious meatloaf wrapped in bacon so
with mashed potatoes green beans and
obviously ketchup oh that's beautiful
yummy butter is so much better the knife
and full amen
really good this is so perfect this is
better than I thought it could ever be
we could never have done this on our own
fries or green don't you feel better
that's all streamlined we're serving a
brand new menu it's just really simpler
but it's better food and it looks better
so we're all excited to serve it it's
going to be fun number
[Laughter]
now that the restaurant and menu have
been vastly improved Chef Ramsay knows
that it is critical that Denise reach
out to the community and so he has made
arrangements for her to do just that
this is an amazing opportunity we're
about to go live you ready I'm ready
let's go you may or may not have known
Gordon Ramsay has been filming here in
town over the weekend we've heard that
he's bringing Denise Whiting the owner
of Cafe hunt with him and that they're
gonna make an announcement of some sort
on our show and they just walked into
the studio good morning hello Gordon how
are you very well thank you it's been a
busy couple days for you we're sure very
busy yeah we've uh yeah we've gone to
Helen back it's been a tough week I'm
gonna hand you over to Denise she's
obviously very excited to be here
I just wouldn't say it
trademarking the word is
not only almost killed me but has just
about killed the business I didn't
understand the whole
culture and how passionate everybody was
about you know hun is in our hearts and
now
I get it I was just doing what business
people do and it was a misstep I am so
sorry for the animosity and the hatred
and
everything that trademarking
[Music]
a word just a word has done please
forgive me
that must have taken a lot of courage to
say that but you never said you were
gonna give the trademark back is that
what you're doing you mean actually
physically handing over the trademark
yeah yeah will you be handing it back
[Music]
you I want to do this maybe I don't
after alienating the entire city of
Baltimore Denise has an opportunity to
make amends you never said you were
going to give the trademark back
is that what you're doing you mean
actually physically handing over the
trademark yeah yeah
[Music]
yes wow this is amazing I am taking that
piece of paper that says it's registered
I'll get it from my attorney I'll take
it off the register I can do that that's
kind of stunning this is for Real it was
never mine to have in the first place
it's just a word it's just wonderful to
have this opportunity to be here to get
foreign
please forgive me
um for everything that I've done Denise
I gotta be honest with you I wasn't on
your side over the last year I'm on your
side now thank you guys thank you Gordon
from the bottom of my heart
thank you so much this is an incredible
opportunity that I've been handed and
I'm not going to take it for granted all
right well thank both of you for coming
in this morning appreciate it I
appreciate your time thank you so much
Maria's coming up next it's 10 o'clock
immediately following Denise's
announcement on the radio Chef Ramsay
arranged for a press conference to make
sure that everyone in Baltimore
understands that the niece is giving up
the trademark of the word hunt I didn't
mean to steal something or to take
something and I apologize
[Music]
for the remainder of a stay Gordon and
his team got in the trenches with Chef
Greg and his staff work as a team work
as a team where he implemented a new
system for me it doesn't even look hot
enough stone cold come on back in and as
Cafe hun became a fun place to work at
once again guys you're doing a great job
you're doing awesome John thank you
Dottie beautiful the people of Baltimore
returned I appreciate your saying thank
you and I really want you to do well and
the business is clearly headed in a
positive direction these are fantastic
[Music]
result is heavy touchdown
Chef Ramsay took a lost owner and put
her back on the road to success and
nobody realizes that more than Denise
Whiting with all the odds stacked
against you you pulled it off
I feel amazing I've been given a gift a
great gift and an amazing opportunity
and I will be forever grateful thank you
thank you have a bloody tough week I
have my life back I have my restaurant
back thank you Gordon Ramsay thank you
for this opportunity thank you everybody
wow good night hon